you had a point ever since buying
nowhere from The Collector we don't have
time for
a trip mix it up for what why do you
want it I love that this is a big deal
and they're just throw it out there
what's old news for them it's like yeah
whatever we live here I'm fascinated
oh it looks all burned
it's burnt away
oh so this looks like a painting welcome
back to New rockstars the Guardians of
the Galaxy holiday special confirms that
the Guardians have now taken residence
in nowhere after purchasing it from The
Collector other than the coolest
possible home base for what other
reasons might the Guardians want this to
be their home and what trouble will it
get them into no no
okay so the way the screen is built I
can't see the script
Ure
this is inside Marvel let's do
Rockstar's weekly Marvel reaction show
this week we are talking about the
Guardians of the Galaxy holiday special
in Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 because
this holiday special set up quite a bit
of it I mean we're expecting something
kind of like you know just kind of a an
off ramp like werewolf by night we're
just gonna like chill with the Guardians
for an hour but no no James gonna
actually use this holiday special to
give a quite a bit of a prologue to what
he's playing for volume three we're
gonna be talking about that this episode
I'm Eric Boss with me today is Jessica
Clemens and MD hi what's going on dude I
freaking loved every second of this
special like it didn't even feel like it
was like 43 minutes it felt like I don't
know how we managed to jam so much in
that short amount of time but like James
God is a freaking genius like that
special made me feel so good on the
inside uh my holiday fuzzies are here
I'm I'm ready for the holiday season
yeah me too how do we feel in general
about like I was not expecting to feel
this emotional maybe it was something
about that Ralph boxy style rotoscope
animation at the beginning it really got
me and
you know like was it supposed to be like
um Rudolph the Red-Nosed Reindeer or
like the hemiser kind of bit or was it
following a different holiday thing
James gonna said that he's pulling from
a couple different things but he said
that one thing he wanted to pull from
was the holiday special for the Star
Wars holiday special how we cut to the
Boba Fett animation uh but then in terms
of the style of stupid buddy animation
who does the uh the Robot Chicken and
they did a lot of Roto scoping but yeah
it also feels like the animated Frosty
the Snowman How the Grinch Stole
Christmas
um uh the Charlie Brown Christmas
special like a couple different things I
think you need a bit of animation for it
to feel like Christmas right even elf
has that moment where he's like Mr
Narwhal
I really love that choice I thought it
was like a really nice way to like give
that holidays like spirit because like
you know in where we'll fight night we
got the black and white that sort of
like set the tone so like now we have
the little uh rotoscoping I'm like
Marvel Studios just how to make a good
prison they do they do before we dive in
uh have you ever wanted to see some of
the new rockstars team live and in
person yeah well if you're in Los
Angeles this weekend now is your chance
come see me in the cast of new
Rockstar's break room live at La
Comic-Con this Sunday December 4th at 10
30 a.m for tickets and more information
check out the uh check out
comicla.com uh so I'm very excited to do
that but then this may just be something
that's uh only gonna be enjoyable for us
internally here but uh I Mt is gonna
meet the rest of the team and us for the
yes and for the first time ever we're
gonna have like an uh an in-office hang
out and visit so you may see some of us
in person for some of these shoots I'm
so excited I'm going to be going to
California the West Coast for the first
time in my life I don't know why your
trees are so tall but I'm going to find
out myself look here why are donuts so
Duncan that's what I say to you because
they're delicious we are Krispy Kreme
over here well Krispy Kreme House
Christmas cream only y'all don't know
what you're missing out you're missing
out on some mediocre coffee
you are absolutely saying that yeah I'm
excited to see all it's it's odd because
I'm also in a different city from the
main new Rockstar's office I'm in San
Francisco the rest of new rock stars is
in uh Burbank and then you know empties
on the east coast and we're all kind of
spread out all over so and it's awesome
to see each other in person because like
I'm always surprised by how like tall or
short people are right I can't wait to
see how tall everyone is I just need to
have that in my break because I don't
know I do not I'm six foot three is Mt
like secretly swole empty and it's gonna
be like small group I'm actually five
feet tall and I'm just Mega swole I'm
like a strong Scrappy dude his legs are
like tree trunks he's just like a
massive bodybuilder from the waist down
exactly no I have little baby legs like
Deadpool and Deadpool one and the
Deadpool two I would I would take your
little shoes off and I go look at the
little toesies look at the little
whereas I'm surprisingly just like Modoc
I'm just like a huge head and a tiny
body it just kind of wobbles around and
screams and like your toes are just CGI
dated just like you just have a huge
head pretty much all right let's dive
into nowhere speaking of speaking of
huge heads with like weirdly rest of
their Anatomy missing
um so huge hit sorry
I I made it so no head joke I was like
so huge head
sorry continue oh god I've never
apologize
the Guardians by nowhere uh I think
that's the the whole story with nowhere
is I think the big question coming out
of a holiday uh special for the
Guardians that we're all kind of
puzzling over but a quick breakdown of
the timeline of what we know uh nowhere
was was wrecked by Thanos in 2018 during
Avengers Infinity War when Thanos took
the reality Stone from The Collector and
that was the last time we saw it when it
was mostly on fire I think that's why
it's now looking like charred uh or
burnt out but you also see some
construction if you look closely as they
fly away from it now in the aftermath of
Avengers end game Thor teamed up with
the Guardians of the Galaxy and they
took a bunch of missions before they
parted ways we saw that in the First Act
of Thor love and thunder and James Gunn
said that in his mind Thor and the
Guardians were together for a few weeks
uh the holiday special Guardians volume
3 are significantly after that and James
Gunn has explained that the Guardians
got nowhere for cheap because after
Thanos the celestial skull was just
really a burnt out husk uh Gunn also
explained to Daniel Chen on the ringers
mint Edition podcast a lot more about
what the Guardians are doing there let's
actually take a listen to that well but
it plays the volume three and that they
just this is where they live now this is
their home nowhere is the home of
Guardians of the Galaxy
um you see they've they've you know have
a bunch of refugees now that live with
them who come from different parts of
the planet who's have their homes
destroyed or heard or whatever maybe by
Thanos Maybe by other things and um and
they have this sort of group of outcasts
around them and they're started their
own little Society of of people in this
abandoned giant Celestial head oh I
didn't know that they were refugees I
thought they were just like people that
were still there that survived the
Flames the flame
that makes more sense so specifically
the Guardians of the Galaxy are using
nowhere not just as their new home but
it's a kind of refugee Colony for
victims of thanos's Conquest both people
who were on the the colony of Celestia
of uh nowhere that was like kind of a
mining Colony but also people on other
planets and other places that have just
kind of used this as like a new place to
settle yeah it also brings I'm sorry I
was gonna say it also think makes you
think like what other planets did that
because there's probably a planet's not
close to Nowhere that other planets are
doing it so that he just opened up a can
of worms he could do it for any people
he did potentially right like we know
xandar must have been pretty messed up
in order for this to get the power Stone
we haven't checked in with xandar since
yes oh
I really hope they talk about in
Guardians 3 please talk about Xander
maybe they will go that's actually cool
I didn't notice that I mean like the
Nova Corps pretty much shows up in every
Guardians movie so they I feel like
they'll probably mention it I think so
too uh a couple questions that we need
to ask one do the Guardians want
something else here on nowhere and two
does their stewardship of nowhere make
them potential targets for some incoming
threat
um now I expect the collector will have
moved most of his remaining Treasures
with him uh at least any of them that
were destroyed but he did leave Cosmo
there Cosmo was one of his treasures
there uh which is something we have a
lot of questions about Cosmo of course
um is it possible that something
valuable would have would have been left
behind there like the Embers of Genesis
because that was you know that was the
artifact uh from the Guardians t'challa
episode and what if that was
Interstellar dust that could be used to
Spring forth vegetation on an entire
planet that was uh starving
um with only just a small fragment of
the Embers of Genesis would have taken
the Embers of Genesis with him
um could it be that the reason the
collector gave up nowhere was that
secretly he knew this skull was kind of
haunted it was like haunted terrain or
maybe sacred remains that he knew
somebody the other celestials would come
back here to check in on it I mean
eventually or to like like a crime scene
and he's like setting up shop in a crime
scene uh what are your thoughts uh Jess
Mt what do you guys think I like the
second part really spoke to me that and
I brought this up yesterday on the break
room where I'm like now they have an
actual Target on their back because
they're always being chased in every
movie and now they have a home base
which doesn't seem like a good idea
that seems like a really dangerous idea
I just assumed The Collector gave it to
him because he was like well I'm not
gonna pay to rebuild this place it's
probably a lot of time and money and
he's like they don't like me here oh
yeah I'm not gonna rebuild this The
Collector basically sold nowhere because
he was using nowhere to make money like
he moved he found this head he was like
yo I could sell this a brain matter this
the spinal fluid to the black market and
make a bunch of money so I can buy more
[ __ ] because like that's his ultimate
goal he wants more [ __ ] and so now that
he can't do that now that like Thanos
destroyed all the celestial material
he's just like I need to make money off
of this because I I cannot live like
there's no point for me to be here
anymore and uh James Gunn has said in
previous Tweets in the past that he has
other collections in different places in
the in the universe so like this is just
one installation of just all of this
stuff so he's just like you know what
I'm gonna make this money and leave uh
because I don't really need this anymore
but like you said
um this does really put the a huge
Target on the Guardians back because
they've never really had a home base
before and we know from guardians too
that The Sovereign particular Aisha very
pissed off still at the Guardians and he
she he she wants them dead and that's
why she's making Adam Warlock
um so have them having a base is not
good for them in the long run
um because yeah The Sovereign are still
on their on their butts is it gonna be
such a shitty thing if they if that if
like warlock comes out of warlock comes
or someone comes and just puts it back
into fire just burns out nowhere
third time a third time there is flames
on nowhere that would be so tragic and
so annoying I just at that point be like
someone call erisham someone get this
Celestial hair if I ever should get this
hand someone buried his head please yeah
send it away these are all very
interesting thoughts I I you know one
thing Mt and I were talking about a
little earlier was like what is what
constitutes the uh corpse matter of a
Celestial like what is a Celestial uh is
it the armored body is it armor all the
way down into that body it kind of
looked like it was this like ancient
stone uh We've speculated they could be
made of vibranium you know
um but like it could be uru or it could
be some other material uh and is that
but is it armor is there flesh
underneath it when we saw ego he was
just kind of a floating boltzmann brain
made out of light that kind of
manifested that light into carbon matter
uh there's a are they a kind of plasma
so the fact that they were like you know
still mining brain tissue and fluid and
spinal tissue made it sound like there
was like carbon uh tissue there was a
flesh to a Celestial and my wondering
here's what I'm thinking I think
celestials are beans made out of light
and they use this kind of like armored
form so that they we can see a corporeal
humanoid form but underneath that is
light when we saw airsham talked it was
like glowing light from underneath I
think celestials are made of light and
that that light went out when when
nowhere died but there's some kind of
Trace soul and here's my crazy Theory I
think there's some kind of soul that is
haunting
I think there's some kind of like uh
there's gonna be some kind of voice that
is like haunting them and is like uh
giving this land a kind of cursed uh
quality to it uh I think that's going to
be something that is that is like a
beacon to the other celestials to come
back do you think it will just be a
floating ghost riped head throughout
space and it'll be I mean I like it also
because the storytelling wise we're
going into that direction already so
it's like this is a floating haunted
house don't go to that planet it's
dangerous well if you think about
technically technically the MCU does
have a ghost of a Celestial in play
because we know from the comics that uh
the necrosword was made of the the Torso
the energy of nowhere and so like
basically that's sort of like the
nowhere's little ghost haunting the
Marvel Universe then making it worse
um so I I do like the idea of there
being like a nowhere energy Essence just
being like Oh you mess with me I'm Gonna
Get You collector better run oh that'd
be funny I mean doesn't this sound like
a classic horror film of a young group
of people moves into like an old uh
burnt out Shack and they're like we can
Spruce this up we can fix it up it's a
fixer-upper we'll flip it right and then
they find out that there's some kind of
like demonic Spirit that's possessing
this land and then it messes with them
it's the walls start bleeding I don't
think the Guardians would be afraid of
it that's the thing I can't see nebula
running away from it I can't see rocket
running away from it I see them I'm not
saying it's gonna be like Scooby-Doo and
they're like
I mean Scooby-Doo James Gunn has
directed Two Scooby-Doo movies it's true
this isn't his blood that's Scooby true
wait a minute wait a minute it might
happen that's funny which one you want
some more director he directed
slither.io
oh that's good to think about that's
good to keep in mind that is good to
know yeah I don't know if it'll get a
silly but I think it will make this uh
like I think the fact they're now
custodians of of nowhere it's it's gonna
be a pain in the ass for them I think
it's not going to be just like an easy
thing for them to have to handle I think
it's gonna be hard I think it's gonna be
a greater challenge for that and I I
honestly do believe that this um the
high evolutionary is probably going to
use the skull of nowhere
um for whatever he's planning because
like we know from um there's this really
interesting run in the comics um with
the high evolutionary
um wanting to make a Celestial I think
it's it's a it's the black Galaxy Saga
um where um the high evolutionaries just
basically messing around with
um Celestial stuff and he's very
interested in um in recreating that life
I think that he this High evolutionary
is going to go to whatever is left of
ego and then go to this skull and be
like I'm gone I'm going to make my own
Celestial by putting this brain inside
of this empty hand and like make a new
being because my why not this is what I
do
um so I don't know I just I think it'd
be really interesting if those elements
um came into play during the third Act
of Guardians three
um because High evolutionary is a weird
dude he's just weird I don't think he's
gonna die
but that would be I hope not I really
hope that sounds like that actor's
amazing the more and more the MCU kills
characters that I don't believe should
be able to Die the more I start losing
not Faith but I'm like this is a this
isn't correct
how easy was to kill Gore I was like
wait a minute
I'm honestly glad that this special like
confirmed that the collector survived
because I was pretty I was like did he
die because he's an elder of the
universe he can't die that that timeline
was so confusing because you're like
okay where is he
where is he what's going on
reality Stone uh projection drops and
you just see like Benicia was like it's
like where are you
confused with it
are you hiding under the uh the fire was
Thanos doing that was that thanos's
little like imagination project
[Laughter]
like cry on her knees he's just like I
would I would love a fan it was just
kept like spotting the a fake collector
just to Hype himself up it's like every
time you just hit those Champions
magnificent magnificent every time
Thanos takes a dump he just projects
with the reality Stone exactly
this is the biggest dump so far
magnetism
I mean ever since ebony ma died he needs
a new hype man he needs someone to kiss
his ass so that's perfect things got
silly and gross um we have a lot of
questions about Guardians holiday
special we want to uh dig into a few
more of them first thank you to smile
brilliant for sponsoring this episode if
you have ever considered whitening your
teeth you might be confused by all the
variations of teeth whitening on the
market well thankfully smile brilliant
is here to explain the science behind
teeth whitening to make you feel
comfortable about choosing the correct
method stop the expensive guess and test
method when it comes to teeth whitening
and Oral Care many of the at-home
products on the market don't even work
as intended LED lights are novelty items
strips neglect the gum lines crevices
and molars often ensuring that the
remaining stains will be more prominent
plus strips use hydrogen peroxide which
always results in Greater tooth
sensitivity in comparison to carbamide
peroxide charcoal is abrasive and wears
down the enamel and whitening toothpaste
only works on the surface stains and
like charcoal it's abrasive so what
actually works well the number one
product recommended by dentists is a
custom fitted Trey historically
dispensed by only dentists at a price of
like you know 300 to a thousand dollars
that changed more than 10 years ago when
smile brilliant came up with the
Innovative lab direct process head on
over to smilebrilliant.com and get
custom fitted teeth whitening trays or
night guards if you grind your teeth
they also have a whole Suite of
professional oral care products such as
an electric toothbrush water flosser
Dental probiotics and much more and
right now they're having a holiday sale
with discounts up to 50 off of the
normal price freshen your breath and
look with Marvel five and save an
additional five percent off their
holiday sale that's marvel5 at
smilebrilliant.com we also want to thank
Helix sleep for sponsoring this episode
sleep is so important and here at new
rockstars We Trust Helix to protect our
sleep with the best mattresses in the
world I have a helix mattress as does MT
recently producers active producer John
also got Helix mattresses Helix sleep
has a quiz that takes just two minutes
to complete it matches your body type
and your sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you everybody's
unique and Helix knows that so they have
several different mattress models to
choose from they have soft medium and
fur mattresses mattress is great for
cooling you down if you sleep hot
matches great for spinal alignment to
prevent morning aches and pains even the
Helix plus mattress or plus size
sleepers producer Zach took the Helix
quiz and was matched with a midnight
Luxe mattress because he's a side
sleeper that needed a softer mattress
and now he doesn't wake up with a sore
shoulder or neck like he did with the
other mattresses just go to
helixsleep.com inside marble take their
two-minute sleep quiz and they'll match
you to a customized mattress that will
give you the best sleep of your life
they have a 10 year warranty and you get
a tried out for 100 nights risk-free
Helix is operating up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helixsleep.com inside
Marvel all right let's get back to the
Guardians of the Galaxy right now
um why do we think it's important that
mantis is ego's daughter why was it so
necessary to reveal in this holiday
special I honestly feel like
um Marvel is setting up mantis to be a
lot more powerful than a lot of people
realize in the MCU mostly because of a a
deleted scene from Infinity War uh that
has to do with mantis uh where uh Doctor
Strange I if I'm remembering this
correctly Doctor Strange basically tasks
mantis to take the souls that Thanos
pushed out of the bodies of the
Guardians and bring them back into the
into their mind
um and she she's like I can't do that
doctor strange is like you can do that
you just don't know that you can do that
um and so I think that that was the
Marvel Studios way of sort of teasing
mantis's
um you know Celestial powers and
Celestial connection
um because why did he assume she could
do that wait am I well we know well like
he he did see the future um
right the yeah so like he probably knows
he knew stuff about like Spider-Man and
mantis before he even saw them
um so yeah so I feel like Doctor Strange
just knew I love that that she had she
had more power and um I think that this
could be like moving forward like maybe
we could see mantis potentially maybe
potentially hold getting the the mantle
of Star-Lord down the line because um
you know we we know that the you know I
know that Star-Lord is a is a Peter
Quill thing but like I think that Peter
Quill is called Star-Lord because his
father is a star and he's he is a um
Celestial being so if mantis has the
same father then I think mantis also has
the rights to be a Star-Lord if she so
chose
um and I think we're really fun
um if um this Celestial being half
Celestial
um I I think that
um this this ability to manipulate the
human soul
um is probably gonna come into you play
in the future Marvel movie
project I agree also everything you said
I think that sounds amazing also I just
don't think siblings last long and then
see you so
as soon as they're like we're siblings I
was like you guys Gotta Die I was like
one of you I don't know which one it is
but one of you guys gotta go
you can decide but what do you got to
get out of here it's true I feel like
Peter Quill I don't know like maybe he
could die I don't know that's so
interesting where is he gonna where
would he go I like the idea of mantis
becoming a new Star-Lord because she's
also technically a Star-Lord uh I would
also I it's so interesting that I think
is the biggest part of the story for
those two is just like what does that
mean for her as a daughter of a
Celestial I think that's more the
biggest takeaway than like what's their
Dynamic gonna be now
right what are they going to share on
the ship I think it's more about like
she has something now she has something
like maybe Adam Warlock will like do
they will come and like because she's
also a different being she's not a human
so maybe her powers from a Celestial is
just insane and we just haven't seen
well
um I I'm wondering about mantis's
timeline right like her species I would
assume ages differently than than terens
do
um and like does she she her job the way
ego used her was to carry all of her
Gill or carry all of his guilt so she
knew everything he did she knew all
those bodies were piled up did she might
she have known like the moment that ego
implanted the tumor in Meredith Quill's
brain and she might know something about
Meredith quill that Peter doesn't know
because I think the reason that Peter
could carry the light is because
something he got from Meredith quill
because all of all of ego's other
progeny you know couldn't handle it so
there's something about Meredith quill
that's a secret to all this and and I
think mantis might know it yeah there's
a huge possibility there because mantis
seems to have like powers to interface
with the with the with the mind and like
her the reason why ego had her there was
to help him go to sleep because ego
cannot sleep without mantis and um for
some reason he needs to sleep to dream
about his progeny I think that may be
potentially with um with ego dreaming
maybe ego is actively looking through
the lenses of the people that he's given
tumors and like he's dreaming of like
hey all right here's my next kid but
here's all right there's a there's a kid
on spartax seven and uh I gotta get that
kid and so like he just when he wakes up
he's like okay now I have I have new
kids to go kill
um so I don't know there's something
really interesting going on do you think
she was maybe the Mantis and Peter Quill
mom storyline could just be that like he
knows his mom very well just like she
was a really nice person the memories
that I had to get rid of for him were
all very nice and I saw or die maybe she
knows that like maybe her mom is like
still living maybe she like is aware of
like other parents that are like still
alive and she's like yeah I feel like
the deal I mean I could be wrong but
like I think that the the mother has to
die or
um the child to be born I think that
that's the that's the I think the tumor
might actually uh because he says like
in Guardians 2 he says
um the the task of grafting my DNA onto
a species the grafting makes me feel
like the tumor is what changes the like
what what allows Meredith to make a
Celestial baby and like that tumor has
to is he puts in every single of his
mates to actively make a Celestial baby
so I think it's harder than it is um
because like with biological beings
which ego is not he's just like an
extension of himself we have you know we
have the sperm and all that stuff I'm
not gonna go into the berms of the beads
but um because ego's different I think
he had to put the tumor to um impregnate
mates
um his hopes I think all the parents
died
um all the moms anyway which is quite
sad but that's just my assumption
um interesting well Mt I know you're
working on uh a theory video about
mantis I can't wait to see it I think
you obviously have some really cool
ideas about what's next for her
um yeah now but meanwhile Jess you made
I love this video that you made about
Bucky's arm like how these hot Bucky's
arms
so he wanted to tweet about it until he
chose the day after my video to come out
to tweet him
here's my question for both of you how
seriously should we take James Gunn's
answers about Bucky's arm in particular
it seemed like he was kind of joking a
bit about it that's just like nebula was
in such a holiday spirit that she ripped
off Bucky's arm the thing is remember
remember when
um 411 thunder came out and uh tiger
watiti was like I mainly put the goats
in there at this point because it's
messing with James Gunn because he has
to pick up or do wherever where I left
off and I was like what if that is just
a train of things that directors do
within the MCU especially directors have
got at least two or three movies they're
like yeah we can just he's in play and
since he's on his way out he's just like
yeah next director has to figure out
what the arm did like the neck whoever's
doing that to figure it out now so
that's why I think we it is going to be
a true thing it's going to be a true
thing because the next director has to
deal with figuring out how to make it
true whether even it's like a little
callback of Bucky being like yeah this
crazy alien girl tried to rip my arm off
the other day or something and that that
confirms that it's a fake arm I
genuinely think it's a fake I would not
want to take it too seriously but I
think him saying that and him on his way
to DC he's allowed to say it and what he
says goes so we're just gonna have to
deal with it hey
yeah no I honestly do I do think it's
it's a real arm and I think that nebula
literally went up to Buggy and ripped it
off
um mostly because I think that I like to
think that nebula's like you owe me for
saving your life so like this arm is
fine I think that'd be hilarious because
like she didn't have the Avengers they
never even really talked nebula and
Bucky so like if but if she shows up
because she was on Space when he was in
wakanda fighting so he's gonna be like
who are you
I think that they did talk because man
just was like Steve and she gave him a
hug I think they all just like hung out
after the battle
and passing but also nebula is dealing
with her new sister and after killing
her past self so I don't think she
actually Manchester is probably happy
but nebula's like okay this is your
lover be be happy about it also I just
killed my past self so are a different
version of myself so I'm just it there's
too many things that makes me so upset
about this because I'm like first off
we're assuming in that like two hours
that they found out what Christmas was
and to get the gifts she flew to Earth
pinpointed Bucky's location ripped off
his arm and then came back
I think she had already had it for some
other reason yeah that's why I agree
with you Jess I think just saying she
was in a Christmas spirit and ripped it
off I mean there was a lot that got like
Groot made all those little dioramas in
like 15 minutes from himself so it's a
little easier and quicker that's the
only that was my only connection it
makes more sense that group made that
than she was able to fly back to Earth
just from suddenly getting inspired by
the Chris I think she already had it yes
um but there's two ways this could have
worked one like we forget that like
nebula was on Earth for the entire Blitz
like she came back with Tony Stark so
she was there for five years what was
she doing during those five years she
could have gotten to know the wakandas
stealing [ __ ] but Bucky's arm dusted
with him his vibranium are adjusted with
him so it's not like it was lying around
anywhere but she could have like maybe
they had backup arms which yeah like
most of her are cybernetic Parts at this
point maybe she forged some relationship
with the koye we don't really know
they're too bald beautiful they could
have like to know each other
um so there's that but secondly I think
it's I think the simpler answer is that
the Bucky that we see in Thunderbolts
it's just gonna have a new arm yeah I
think he's gonna have like a new upgrade
arm and then that's how they're gonna
explain it that he's just like retired
they were always taken I honestly I
honestly believe that the arm is like
symbolic towards like basically who owns
Bucky at the time for lack of a better
term because like the first arm was the
Hydra arm or the the Soviet Union arm
the second arm was the wakandan arm and
like this third arm is likely going to
be Val's arm
um when he joins the Thunderbolts so
like because she's gonna be working
under Val
um so yeah I think that we he and Bucky
is inevitably going to lose that arm
pretty much every time because action
figures have to be sold that's the real
reason
um so like he was always that vibrating
arm was always gonna go to me I'm like
Val what arm are you gonna make that's
better than the vibranium arm unless it
is a missile because
if she gets more vibranium I guess
that's why I'm like are you gonna you
have to have that Val I just don't think
your arm's gonna be better than what
this vibranium one is but that arm the
new arm will probably not have that fail
safe that all the wakandans know about
and no one else really does right maybe
he'll get one that he can keep yeah I
honestly think that that might you know
reel Bucky into the Thunderbolts because
like if Val's like hey look new
vibranium arm he's like all right I
guess I'll hear you out because that
vibranium arm was pretty sick
um so I don't know
um
um another question we should talk about
uh this special more than most other MCU
titles gets real referency uh and adopts
a lot of stuff as as now MCU Cannon now
uh Kevin Bacon references Batman which
is fine because eternals already
referenced Batman and Superman but they
basically said a Gobot killed drax's
cousin not only do GoBots as a media
thing as like a Tonka media Transformers
uh uh competitor exists that kids play
with that they that the lore of GoBots
exists so that's crazy but then the fact
that Kevin Bacon is exist like the fact
that Kevin Bacon is already a Nexus uh
being in our reality
make it so if Kevin bacon is MCU Cannon
is X-Men first Class also MCU Cannon
no yes yes two different people it's two
different people because the guy in
X-Men first what do you mean two
different people wait wait wait am I
missing something did Kevin Bacon appear
the movie He plays Sebastian Shaw yes
first class he's Sebastian Shaw and that
so Sebastian Shaw exists in the Now
Kevin Bacon exists I don't think we
addressed Sebastian Shaw as Kevin Bacon
as semester shop but I think if there is
that moment someone's gonna be like you
look a lot like Sebastian
I think someone can make that joke
easily yo you I don't know if it's easy
to make that it's easy to make the joke
I guess it's not easy for it to make any
logical sense yo you know what's funny
um considering that um we had this this
is the second time this has happened
sort of because like with uh Ralph boner
Ralph boner was also an actor much like
Kevin Bacon was so it's like what if
we're looking at a scenario we're we're
X-Men first Class is legitimately a
movie
just them addressing it like that was a
really good movie
I mean this has already been kind of an
issue anytime they've referenced like
movies that exist like they've you know
Captain America has like Star Wars The
Beatles he has all these things like
every movie that they reference point
break they reference Lebowski and the
fact that Jeff Bridges is in LA in The
Big Lebowski and then he also plays
Obadiah stain this has already been a
problem from the first Iron Man movie
let's be honest
um but like now it's just getting so
overt about it just the the rules of
canonicity should we just like give up
trying to trying to make sense of this
really I think it's just um I I
I I truly honestly believe that like
this Marvel Studios put Kevin Bacon into
this universe to sort of like continue
that Ralph boner type of narrative so
that later on when we when we like go to
Secret Wars and get like a real
understanding of the Multiverse we'll
realize that like both Kevin Bacon and
Ralph boner are just variants of their
um multiversal selves and that of the
X-Men first Class is like in a separate
like probably new uh TVA
um just you know Multiverse bundle in
general so that's why we can have um uh
what's a classic Loki and the old guy
from Logan I forget his name
um being played by uh the same actor and
Chris Evans
um
now that Patrick Stewart I'm Viking on
his name he's a brilliant actor I would
keep blank on everyone's name but
E Grant Richard E Grant Richard E Graham
yeah he played like do that made a the
Logan clone in Logan that's right he
played uh yeah yeah yeah so like it's
just I think that we're like Marvel
Studios wants to make a delineated
difference between the X-Men universe
and the uh Marvel Universe by
deliberately putting these actors in
different roles in the MCU so that when
we finally get the big pictures like oh
yeah the MCU is different from the X-Men
Universe because the these actors are
are re like doing a different role in
that Universe
I think it's okay when actors are just
playing different roles in different
franchises that doesn't confuse me the
difference is that the MCU is saying the
actor that we know of Kevin Bacon exists
in the MCU playing roles that we know
Kevin Bacon having played between uh you
know footloose and uh and his role in
Friday the 13th so like one of those
other roles was an X-Men movies so I
think that's that's different than just
like you know lyric Lawrence Fishburn
plays characters in different yeah I
don't know but it's fun it's all a joke
and I
yeah I can't wait until they just show
his IMDb page on his computer
and then it says it and it says it and
then we're like it's a movie it's a
movie and a movie right I think this is
all just silly I think it's we're all
just
literally is doing this to mess with the
people that are us James got into this
everything in this movie is to mess with
us and then all those tweets he sent
following or the mess with us and that's
why I'm gonna box him I'm gonna find him
empty set me yeah no
James God is my friend I love him you're
gonna knock on James Gunn's uh door and
you're gonna appear in his Vivint
Security camera and then just yeah
through the glass
just hop around his home
[Laughter]
like mantis's action in this was like my
all-time favorite
like mantis was like a an all-time high
like favorite Marvel character for me so
like seeing her in her own special made
me so happy because like she deserves
her own spot she deserves a spotlight
because like a palm is just such a good
actress I love her we'll actually leave
it there for this episode of inside
Marvel
um we I feel like we cover a lot but
there's still so many questions we have
hopefully we'll get a Guardians volume 3
trailer sometime soon
because there's I'm so looking forward
to this movie even more now
um but you can follow Jessica and Lulu
underscore Clements follow Mt at
masterton follow me hey boss subscribe
Marvel where we get your podcast thank
you so much for watching and we'll see
you next week everybody bye-bye
foreign